ahora que ya tenemos una visión de lo
que es la tangente común con pendiente
positiva respecto al círculo y la
hipérbola obtenemos ahora algunas
restricciones especiales sobre esta
pendiente y dicho gráfico y bueno esta
línea que pinte en el último vídeo de
color rosa formalmente vendría siendo y
igual a m x + b pues es una línea donde
m va a representar la pendiente y la b
representa lo que intersecta alayes
ahora pensemos que restricciones
deberían haber en m
yves y esto sí es tangente al círculo y
bueno quizás podrías verte un poco
tentado al saltarte algunos cálculos y
figurar te fuera de la pendiente en
cualquier punto a lo largo del círculo y
será una forma fácil de poderlo figurar
simplemente tendríamos que razonar que
si esta línea es tan gente del círculo
simplemente va a interceptarlo en un
solo punto y como ves te estoy señalando
aquí la línea que interceptaría en un
solo punto y lo vamos a igualar a esta
ecuación a la ecuación que interceptará
a el círculo y en realidad esto es en lo
que me voy a centrar en este vídeo
quizás más adelante
en otro vídeo me voy a dedicar a hacer
lo mismo pero para la hipérbola y bueno
la lleva a ser igual a esa ecuación
explícita que ya pusimos de la línea y
la del círculo sería como en el vídeo
pasado nos quedaría x cuadrada massieu
cuadrada menos 8x y todo esto va a ser
igual a cero entonces lo que podríamos
realizar sería como con las dos
expresiones sustituir en este caso y en
la del círculo y ver también las
restricciones que habría tanto para él
como para b pero lo podríamos sustituir
aquí y e irlo elevando al cuadrado y
luego dedicarnos a ver cuál será la
única intersección que es la que
intersecta en un solo punto al círculo
así que para realizar entonces dicha
sustitución con ye cuadrada donde es
igual a esto que tenemos por acá vamos
ir elevando al cuadrado entonces será
cuadrada igual a m cuadrada por x
cuadrada más 2 mpx + b cuadrada y todo
lo que hicimos es elevar el cuadrado no
esta expresión así que entonces ahora
sustituyendo esta expresión x
y obtenida de cuadrada por aquí donde
estamos encerrando y entonces
proyectando este punto hacia el eje de
las equis o donde lo intersecta entonces
vamos a tener que ser a todo esto x
cuadrada más m cuadrada por x cuadrada
más 2 m por b por x más b cuadrada menos
8x y todo esto va a ser igual
y exactamente aquí menos 8x y todo esto
va a ser igual a 0 y si queremos
reescribir lo esté este x cuadrada la
tenemos en los dos términos entonces
vamos a tratar como de factorizar o
vamos a agrupar ambos términos entonces
sería m cuadrada más uno que está x x
cuadrada y al desarrollarla no tiene que
quedar exactamente lo mismo y luego
tenemos este término que tiene en común
el x con el de por acá entonces vamos a
tener más 2 m por b menos 8 y a la vez x
x y finalmente este término b cuadrada y
lo vamos a poner de un color naranja
para que lo vayas identificando más de
cuadrada y todo esto igual a cero
entonces como recordarás nosotros
conocíamos a m y ve de esta ecuación de
por acá de la línea así que lo que
podríamos hacer es utilizar la ecuación
general de segundo grado y encontrar los
valores de las x para nosotros ver donde
intersectan entonces al recordar la
ecuación cuadrática para sacar los
valores de las x recordemos que es menos
b más menos la raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada menos 4 hace todo esto sobre 2a
y esto va a ser igual a equis y esta
ecuación es va a arrojar dos valores
distintos de x pero en este caso nos
interesa saber solamente como un valor
porque es un está un punto porque están
gente no entonces el discriminante o
esto de aquí adentro debería de ser
igual a cero pues si tenemos que esto es
igual a cero entonces vamos a obtener
solamente una solución así que cuando la
línea es tangente con el círculo
nosotros sólo podemos ver que intersecta
en un punto o como en una única solución
entonces si hubiera otro punto que
intersecta que se verá como algo así ahí
tendríamos las dos soluciones de las
equis y no sería una línea tangente
también podría ser el caso que
interceptará todo el círculo como esta
línea y entonces ahí no habría solución
quiere decir que es discriminante o esta
parte de aquí adentro tendría una
respuesta negativa y como mencionamos
por ser una línea tangente entonces esto
tiene que ser igual a cero entonces
ahora que hay que ver quiénes
representan dichos valores esta parte
que está por aquí nos va a representar
al ave pero no te vayas a confundir
porque está estable aquí es por eso que
le elegimos sino simplemente es lo que
está representando a los términos de la
ecuación cuadrática entonces hagamos
esto hay que reescribir entonces dichos
términos clave entonces va a ser 2 m por
b menos 8 al cuadrado como la ave
cuadrada menos menos 4 veces estamos
representando el discriminante la a en
este caso la s m cuadrada más 1 por c
donde se va a ser representado por la b
cuadrada y todo esto entonces va a ser
igual a 0 y entonces si está realmente o
ciertamente hizo una línea tangente si
es una línea tangente entonces vamos a
ver cómo que otro tipo interesante de
cosas podríamos sacar
y nosotros podemos expresar la ve como
una función de m y entonces
desarrollando cada uno de los términos
que tenemos por aquí aquí tendríamos que
elevar este término al cuadrado como
puedes darte cuenta entonces tendríamos
4 por m pero mejor lo voy a pintar de
color azul para que se vaya entendiendo
bien el desarrollo entonces tendríamos 4
por m cuadrada por b cuadrada menos por
el signo que está aquí dos veces el
primero por el segundo entonces estos 8
por 2 16 y 2 veces esto tendríamos menos
32 por m por b y el último número al
cuadrado y esto es simplemente elevamos
todo al cuadrado es un binomio al
cuadrado menos todo esto menos cuatro
veces esta parte de aquí adentro pero yo
creo que mejor si voy a desarrollar todo
vamos a ir multiplicando y expandiendo
el término entonces edad 4 m cuadrada x
b cuadrada unos 4 x 1 4 x cuadrada y
todo esto aquí sí ya igual a 0 y ahora
observando bien estos términos vemos que
se van a cancelar algunos pues tenemos 4
por mb cuadrada y su negativo
o ahora estoy pensando en dividir todo
esto por ambos lados de la ecuación
entre 4 y entonces ahora tendríamos
tendríamos menos 8 m por ve más estoy
viviendo entre 4 entonces 64 entre 4 nos
va a dar 16 más 16 menos b cuadrada y
todo esto igual a 0 y bueno ahora
podríamos volver a consultar la ecuación
de segundo grado la ecuación de una
ecuación cuadrática así que ahora vamos
a tener una restricción no vamos a
esencialmente saber que esto va a estar
interceptando y lo vamos a hacer en
términos de nuestra pendiente y podremos
hacer más adelante lo mismo pero con la
hipérbola y pues tendría que dar
exactamente el mismo tipo de valores al
resolverlo con la pendiente pero yo creo
que mejor ahorita nos enfocamos en esto
ya esto le voy a dedicar los siguientes
dos vídeos y entonces reescribimos esto
de tal forma de que podamos observar o
reconocer que es la misma cosa déjame
déjame solo actualizarlo y déjame
multiplicar esta ecuación de aquí por
ambos lados con un signo negativo que no
me alteren ecuación y este entonces se
quedaría como b cuadrada más 8 mb
-16 igual a cero y entonces ve va a ser
igual va a ser igual a menos 8 menos 8 m
más menos la ra es la raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada donde en este caso b cuadrada
vendría siendo el 8 al cuadrado por m al
cuadrado menos 4 veces en este caso el
coeficiente de este término es 1
entonces va a ser menos 4 x 1 x menos 16
entonces aquí el menos 16 por el menos
cuatro esto nos convierte en un signo
positivo y entonces será 4 por 16 y todo
esto a su vez entre dos veces entre dos
veces pero a como habíamos dicho es
igual a 1 entonces será sobre 2 y
entonces ahora desarrollando o
simplificando tendríamos menos 8 x m más
- la raíz de eso que está por acá pero
aquí 8 el cuadro de 64 y 4 por 16 y 64
entonces podemos sacarlo de la raíz
entonces nos queda 8 por m cuadrada m
cuadrada más 1 que es lo que teníamos
adentro lo que hice fue factorizar el 64
y luego lo saqué de
a raíz porque la raíz de 64 es 8
entonces no nos altera nada y a la vez
todo esto sobre dos y ahora dividiendo
entre el 2 esto va a ser igual a menos 4
m más menos 4 por la raíz de m cuadrada
más 1 y si nosotros nosotros sumamos el
4 nosotros tendríamos vamos a pensar
bien esto por un segundo si nosotros
miramos la línea que aparece en el
camino que yo dibujé nosotros queremos o
el enunciado nos está pidiendo una
pendiente positiva nos interesa una
pendiente positiva y en el orden de
hacer esto yo lo dibujé lo dibujé de tal
manera que dicha pendiente fuera
positiva y que interceptará a esta parte
de borat al círculo y a la hipérbola
entonces esta vez esté b es positivo es
una constante positiva es una línea que
intersecta entonces nosotros queremos
queremos que este valor hay que pensarlo
que también debería de ser positivo
ahora si observamos bien esto de aquí
aquí tenemos un menos 4 m más menos 4
por la raíz no entonces queremos que
esto sea positivo ésta
aquí ya es negativa entonces nos
interesaría que esto de acá fuera
positivo y entonces nuestra única
oportunidad de obtener un término
positivo y sumando el 4 por esta
expresión que está aquí y si tú miras
esto esta raíz va a ser positiva dado
que aquí tenemos una suma y siempre está
elevada al cuadrado
entonces como podrás ver si le sumamos a
este menos 4 m la raíz de m cuadrado
multiplicado por cuatro eso va a ser
mayor que el menos 4 entonces si nos va
a arrojar un término positivo dado que
es la raíz de m cuadrado pero más uno y
en los siguientes vídeos pueda realizar
exactamente lo mismo pero para los
términos de la hipérbola y podemos
llegar a las conclusiones de que la b
que también va a quedar como una función
de de una m también nos va a tener que
arrojar valores este tipo exactamente
igual es dado que es la misma línea que
intersecta con misma pendiente